la famille boulet a découvert une
nouvelle vie grâce à la pandémie nous ça
quand on est rendu avec une vie
ordinaire
le couple travaille au restaurant
familial nous on est deux personnes qui
travaillent deux week-ends de soir et de
nuit jusqu'au petit matin
depuis mars 2020 le couple a un rythme
de vie beaucoup plus stable plus là le
train train quotidien au lieu de peser
lourd sur les épaules de toujours
essayer de trouver du temps mais là
c'est qu'on ne distingue donc en effet
de se trouver des choses à faire pour
mais l'avocat passer du temps avec les
enfants moins de stress une vie moins
trépidante qui fait la sphère de
laurence les invitations à droite on
était quand on s'ennuie de nos amis on
s'ennuie nos familles mais oui c'est de
pas être obligé de de bruyne mans parce
qu'on est fatigué ou des documents parce
que c'est en étant posé we saw 6 et un
poids de moins sur les épaules une
sensation que plusieurs autres québécois
partage c'est justement d'avoir plus de
temps pour moi d'avant le temps que vous
n'ayez dans le temps avec avec qui mon
copain avec mon chien je fais pas dire
que j'étais frustré ça fait quasiment un
an et demi que le gouvernement essaye de
nous convaincre qu'il ya une menace
importante pour le psychologue
certains peuvent même craindre les dix
confinement on attend que cette
intensité cette stimulation notre
système nerveux revient et il ya pas
tout le monde qui est prêt pour ça avec
l'ouverture des terrasses la vie d'avant
arrive en trombe pour laurence le couple
retrouve ses clients avec un petit goût
de nostalgie ici marie josée paquet
comme radio canada montréal